welcome to hurry so bees the Jenna will
rediscover latest tech news and delve
into the newest tech products today
we're taking a look at why this is your
last chance to buy Ram before Ram prices
skyrocket again but before we delve into
that make sure to hit that subscribe
button if you guys like to stay updated
with the latest tech news related to
gaming and pcs so as you guys already
know Ram prices have been really high
for quite a while because of extra
demand and not enough supply
fortunately throughout the last couple
of weeks rent prices were finally
starting to stabilize and some RAM were
even going down in price however this is
unfortunately not going to last very
long and rare prices are going to go up
once again according to DRAM exchange
RAM prices are going to consistently go
up throughout the third quarter of this
year and remain flat throughout the
fourth quarter so it's not looking good
for anyone trying to buy RAM for the new
pcs in the imminent future but why
exactly is this happening what is the
huge fine against Ram companies not
enough to deter them from price fixing
the thing is we are not seeing a price
fixing issue this is a simple supply and
demand issue while RAM Supply has gotten
a lot better and throughout the second
quarter of this year it increased by 3.2
percent and it is expected to increase
another 4.8 percent throughout the third
quarter of this year despite this there
are a lot of huge phone releases coming
up from Apple during the third quarter
of this year like all the iPhone models
and as a result that's going to require
a lot of DRAM and it is going to leave
the DRAM market dry for the average PC
builder and on top of this many D Ram
manufacturing companies are currently in
the process of switching to a lower
manufacturing process and as a result is
very tough to increased production
during such a transition period so when
exactly will RAM prices go down again
well unfortunately it is not going to go
anywhere until 2019 and even once 2019
hits it's going to be a slow down fall
like what we saw this year and it is
going to take at least a full quarter
for prices to return to what they are
right now and so these are the best
I said that we are going to be seeing
for the next nine months so should you
wait for prices to drop in 2019 and what
about ddr5 rim should you wait for that
well in my opinion I don't think Graham
prices are going to be going anywhere
for a really long time from now I think
it is going to take at least nine months
from now for ramp prices to return to
what they are right now and as a result
if you're looking to buy RAM for what it
used to cost then you're going to wait
at least a year from now in all honesty
RAM demand has increased greatly and
whether it is on purpose or not the
supply is just not enough and I don't
see this issue resolved anytime soon
with more and more devices implementing
RAM all the time so in my opinion I
don't think Ram prices are really going
to move until something big happens like
maybe launch of ddr5 Ram but even once
ddr5 ramp
it may cost the same as DVR for RAM does
right now and so this may just be the
new Ram pricing range that we're going
to deal with so what about ddr5 ramp
should you wait for that well there are
a lot of rumors suggesting that the ddr5
Ram will be finalized by the end of this
year but the thing is even if it is
finalized by the end of this year it's
going to take a long time for it to hit
the market so if it is finalized this
year that it probably won't even be
available to us until 2020 considering
all this I think the best course of
action is to just buy right now because
I don't see the RAM pricing situation
getting better anytime soon
there are several sporadic rebates
available on Newegg and just random
deals that pop up here and there and if
you're building a PC in the imminent
future I really recommend it you guys
just catch one of these deals and buy a
ram right now because if you continue to
wait the pricing will only get worse and
you'll most likely have to pay more but
that's just what I think what do you
guys think do you guys think that it is
worth it to buy RAM for such outrageous
prices instead of waiting for a year or
most likely even more make sure to
comment down below what you guys think
because I do read all my comments that
I'm curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like this video then make sure
drop a like and hit that subscribe
button
if you guys like to see more videos just
like this one but until next time bye
[Music]